hi hey how are you i'm good
nice to see you both nice to see you too
yeah canada sends its love
well i think i take it and i send it and
i send
love from africa no i'm just not that's
you know that's our heritage so
l.a africa you know what i'm saying
brooklyn it all comes
from send all the land and we send all
the love back
there you go all the love everywhere for
sure
now let's talk about this movie um they
asked if there was a pill for pure power
for five minutes
would you do it let's just say the power
was for good
and what change would you make right now
if i had the the power i would um
eradicate
the corona virus and we wouldn't have it
it would never have been
and there's that i get rid of all the
haters
haters gotta go nothing but love i got
nothing but love for you baby
i love it it sounds good all right you
two are so good in this movie what
advice
uh jamie would you give or did you give
to dominique on set
and what advice would you pass on to
jamie well i will tell you this
be ready for dominic fishbach she will
be on someone's stage saying thank you
members thank you academy
because she absolutely blows everybody
away in this movie
and when it came to the advice
i was just there she will tell you uh
her her own story but
i learned from her i learned how to be
in the moment i learned how
she has this thing where she could
very quickly be in the moment it could
be
something where there needs to be tears
and things like and she can access that
that is she's a unicorn
yeah hey for sure and what did jamie
teach you
or did jamie teach you anything oh of
course absolutely
happy in a room you could be in a room
with jamie for a minute and
be taught something so there's that but
uh one of the the
main things that i hold on to was when i
was kind of
second guessing myself and feeling like
everything was moving so fast
and i didn't get a chance to do the
analytical work that i normally do like
you know i i've been holding on to that
since school being like
this is how i get to it i know this is
what i need to do
and at a certain point you do have to
let go and so
um i went to him and he said well do you
watch basketball when steph curry runs
up the court and he shoots at three and
it goes in he doesn't question
himself why why it goes in you know like
here i am
because not feeling hard or i'm like not
having
like you understand and then he said
this and i was like it makes sense
he said you've been doing it for so long
and so now for you it's just like
it's like muscle memory is in there and
i get to like
more so enjoy it and and not have to
prove myself i think that
trust yourself right and trust myself
and trust yourself you
this was a really physical movie i mean
you guys were
all over in the places and did you have
to have
cold ice baths at the end of the day to
soothe your bodies like how there was a
lot of physical in this
it was an ice bath right near my chair
that i
rested in before every
submerged right up to here are we ready
just give me one second towels please
towels
uh but it was very it was very listen it
was it was it was a it was a challenging
movie uh as far as the the heart
physical work
and i had to give kudos to dominique
once again because
it it all landed on her at a certain
point standing in this
fake rain and all these different things
that she had to do and so
um it was it was tough but you know what
like i always say man when it's tough
and it's and it's sort of unpredictable
and things
usually the uh the the outcome is
wonderful and the outcome has been
fantastic